when you are taking the capabilities
with ai and data science and you do it
the right way you can create things that
could never be
[Music]
achieved before
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lomitek and
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance opposed hillary stanford leap
and birthright excel
let's talk about disruptive ai welcome
to 20 minute leaders and let's meet your
eye find messer general partner of
disruptive ai
uri is the co-founder and general
partner at disruptive ai fund investing
in early stage startups with great
entrepreneurs and remarkable ai
he also founded ai square forum arab and
israeli ai community in 2019 he retired
as a colonel from the idf as head of a
technological r d unit 3016 8200 in the
intelligence corps responsible for
developing modern data science systems
and ai applications acting as an
exclusive center for computer vision and
imaging technology receiving the israel
defense prize award
july fine mesa welcome to 20 minute
leaders
great to be here thank you so much for
joining me thank you very much for
coming
i'm in your beautiful offices in
artsalia i don't know how much you can
see this amazing view behind us but but
it's spectacular and you're working with
some of the most incredible people in
the world and disruptive aibc you're
looking at early stage
in early stage fun dealing with
artificial intelligence which is you
know your bread and butter but more from
a military perspective but even before
that your deep knee deep into cyber
dealing with some of the most exciting
things that has happened in the israel
ecosystem ever and in the world
unfortunately we can't talk about most
of them
but but at least i'll get to pick you
about your journey a little bit and
about how you see artificial
intelligence as a catalyst and as an
enabler and a little bit about what
you're doing today and working with
early stage companies so tell me a
little bit about yourself and maybe walk
me through a little bit on on your
journey from cyber to ai
great so we pretty got it all all around
and uh i think the
the thing with ai is uh that i found
myself
discovering the area
through my hands through my daily
working and
being so many years with the algorithms
and the cyber
offensive cyber mainly in a200 and
suddenly
this ai as i used to call it this
as a data science uh
something that combines science with
data with big data
entered my office and you know it's a
kind of a funny story because the first
time i did something with the statistic
algorithm is when i used to uh you know
with the hands-on to do algorithms and
to lead
the area of speech analysis
and
it was a successful
project from technological
matters
with some achievements uh in the area of
the you know for intelligence uh
officers and it gave its contribution
but
they didn't like the way the outcome was
a statistic outcome you know like saying
i'm sure in eighty percent that it is uh
the person that is what bothered them in
this this idea that they wanted
uh
they wanted to do it all or nothing even
though you know in the intelligence it's
never all or nothing i remember there
was once uh
just uh sharing you because it was
advertised on the first page in the arts
newspaper so i can share it with you
without killing you at the end of this
conversation
you remember at the gulf uh gulf war uh
the whole world wanted to know is saddam
hussein alive and we got some samples
and they wanted us to decide whether
it's saddam hussein or not
and we did some great work around it uh
not being present by soldiers and uh
they come with their outcome and we uh
actually proved that saddam hussein was
the one that speaks in that uh
conversation that we had in those
samples and
there was one day that i uh
talked about it with the chief of staff
and i think there was the minister of
defense i presented it myself to them
and then the next day it was on the
paper like you know the intelligence uh
experts uh decided that it is uh
talking and he's alive and let's
continue with the with the operation so
this is this is the thing but it was
never absolutely a thing
certain it was something like
statistical and then
a few years later when i took command of
a
of
the unit uh which involves big data and
combines ui
and guise for officers in the internet
corps and then this group enters my my
room they come from the r d group and
they say we have a great idea to do
facial recognition
combining the regular methods but with
deep learning and what i said is uh stop
there
been there done that we close those
projects
our customers doesn't don't like you
know something like estimation they want
they want accuracy and you you know you
can never get there and then they told
me
but you promised that some promised us
some freedom
of uh research and and this is the
freedom we want so this one you're the
head of the r d group of big data and
data right so you have to make some
decisions on on which project do we do
we want to go into that project is uh
with a lot of you know you have to
invest some efforts in that and and
people and then and what i'm also
hearing you see that the people that
came to you there is a sort of this
tension or frustration that on one hand
they're coming and they're brilliant and
you know the the world of dynasty i like
the the best of the best and you never
know where you're gonna end up it's all
about experimentation and so they're
expecting some freedom of to go and
experiment with these products right
it's about 10 years after uh actually it
did well i didn't fail technology from
technology from that side but you got
more
bureaucracy and you know the way of uh
so you have the tension of military with
and then the mission and then the
innovation then to put them together but
then i had my promise because i i
promised them some
freedom of research and they told me
this is where we want our freedom so i
i agree i said okay okay okay so it's
this the discussion is about the freedom
not about the
the uh
the project
let's do it but in one condition i'm
going to review this project every week
in my room you're gonna come here we're
gonna talk about the thing uh the things
and and see how it walks around because
did you feel as a leader that you're
able to then present them with the how
the entire military sees it except for
this r d group why was it important to
you to be very meticulous with this
project i think
um i i thought that i can bring to the
table my experience even from failures
but also from
things like done and succeeding and also
with helping them to gather all the
project
parts all together you know to bring
professors from the academics and the
right
customers to the table and to to
actually help them to figure out what
product will make the most out of this
technology and i wanted to be sure that
something will come out of it and not
just a nice technology um
and yet i believed in them i still
believe in them they're doing great
things some of them are still in the
in the in the idf
and
you have to always know that the people
that comes after you are probably better
than you because they have you and your
experience and they can bring something
else and do something more new but this
very particular moment is the decision
to go to deep learning and machine
learning in in this in this unit it was
the first time the army did something
like that on like
putting it on the table and saying we
are going to
to
let ai uh
yeah be part of our life and
it was very successful we won uh
uh
the defense prize for this species
it was part of this project uh two years
later or one and a half year later
and they got
very successful achievements for the
intelligence and still working and it
was very cool but the the main thing is
in my head i understood that it is this
is the time for ai
this is the time to go forward with the
with that uh
let's say uh
way of thinking on a new way of doing
projects with big data and the
statistical technologies
because we talked before recording this
i came here we talked on the phone
your your passion for ai and your
conviction of where where we're headed
and how it's being used in the world is
is incredible yet you spend decades in
the world of cyber security you're right
you you won prizes you were a colonel
there you you talked about some of the
most sensitive things that that anybody
could experience in the world of cyber
what made you do this switch what what
caused this transition for you where
you're saying like wow i'm rediscovering
this this new phenomenon that i have
such a deep conviction about
well
i i suddenly understood that this is uh
the tool for the future to come that
will impact the most the way we live and
the way we act and the way we take
decisions and how life is going to be in
the next few years and though cyber is a
great area for uh innovation
uh when you
when you're talking when you're taking
the capabilities with ai in data science
and you do it the right way you can
create things that uh could never be uh
[Music]
achieved before uh you know sometimes i
try to explain what it is ai for people
who are not from they're not technical
with no you know understanding in that
area and then i i try to tell them it's
like training your own child how to walk
in the street now you can train him uh
to walk
but then you have to train him to take
decisions along the way when he's a
child you know when to cross the road
when to look right and to look left uh
when to run when to stop
and you can only train it training by
demonstrating
enough with enough
examples
and suddenly we can do that with
computers
we no longer have to
know everything on advanced and write
you know all the rules and all the
uh
options
we can demonstrate the computer with the
situation the way we want them to uh to
end and we can move forward from that
and scale and suddenly you understand
that this is the key for uh creating
technologies that might be more involved
in our life and so
the magic so i decided to go
to move forward with that and not only
with that but you're but you're taking
that same example of working with a team
meeting with them on a weekly basis at
the end you know reaching some
incredible milestones and today you're
doing it in the private sector you're
doing it with an early stage vc fund
with with todd and with these some
incredible incredible partners
what what is your day-to-day like so
what and why why choose this because you
mentioned to me no i have a pension i
could have a comfortable life he spent
you know you got to a level in the army
that very very few people managed to get
to
you know why come here every day now and
work so hard
so so the repression was uh when i
i looked
at the private sector and i looked what
happened with the cyber
and you know with the cyber suddenly
when we discovered the cyber
and we actually
made something
to happen there yeah we established
schools and we have great high tech
around that and there there are a few
places that people with cyber innovation
can go and then i looked at the ai and i
say if i'm an ai guy if i grew up in the
in 800 doing ai
where would i go with my innovation was
the next step where to go
and then i saw that there is no home for
those
those people they are they are they need
there is a lack of of leadership around
it and then i said
to myself let's build a home let's build
a home for the ai community in israel
the innovation ai community i think the
academic has great uh you know uh backup
but but the innovation and the startups
in areas where
they need to see people that understand
in deep tech manners but also
in in you know execution experience way
of looking at things uh that understand
what they want to do and understand how
to leverage their ideas to great things
and
in my daily manner i look at so many
startups and
people that even don't know what they
want to do but they know they want to do
something with ai because they
understand what it can bring to their
to their ideas or to their to their life
and
i see that i can sometime help them to
you know strategically
build a vision around it
people without the experience
will not uh
probably understand all the way that it
takes to do an ai creation to do to
build you know all the experiments and
all this path of trial and error and the
statistical
statistical outputs and if you help them
to build something around it then they
can really appreciate it and do
something with that and this is the way
you can contribute them so companies
that we invest in uh i meet like on a
weekly basis
even if one of my partners my great
partners is sitting in the board so i'm
hoping on the tech side being my
experience
experiencing in ai and how to build the
all this
ai a pipeline the right way and how to
look at things and
what was the shift
from
a very top-down europe bureaucratic
system as in any military or any big
corporate and all of a sudden you're
going to the extreme other end you know
where you have two guys or girls sitting
around and trying to figure out what to
do with no real limitations and no
nobody to report to
just trying to experiment and have a lot
and have a lot of fun how is that for
you personally so i must say that where
i
had my service it was not so well it was
bureaucratic and you have to you know to
know how to navigate
in the system
but
uh the ritual that you are sitting with
young minds sharp young minds with some
ideas or some needs that you have to
find a solution for them and you're
thinking together with them bringing
your experience and bringing their
passion and their i call it the
firepower you know their brain
into the room uh it's the same because
all around the table wants to create
something new that will change something
in our life in our you know in our
defense
area so it doesn't really matter but the
ritual is similar
of course in the private sector we have
to look in different angles
to make sure it's going to be scalable
it's going to be profitable
is it a good investment
you know
so there are other parameters but still
it's a problem tell me a little bit
about the personality of the of the
entrepreneurs that you enjoy working
with that are that are in the ai space
specifically
what what how do you you know picture
the persona of these of these
entrepreneurs that are coming to you and
you say i want to work with you i
believe that you're going to lead to
some disruptive technology in the next
few years
i think uh they come
they bring they bring to the table to
two kind of things one is the deep
understanding
in
in specific domain and i don't really
care of the domain
but they come with deep understanding of
that domain
and the other the another
thing
is
they
kind of feel
not truly know how to do that but they
feel
that taking all the data
around
this domain and doing something with
that will open doors
to to scale and to to do
and to impact and to do many great
things in that area so
people that come
let's take uh for example uh
this company that i'm sitting on the
board it named staircase it's a company
that
[Music]
actually built a
what i call a relationship intelligence
platform now we all have relationships
they are focused on the area of customer
success
and you know customer success is a
post-sale
stage
and we all know that the success is
somehow related to their relationship we
managed to create between two
organizations right and
they understood that
taking some ideas from the intelligence
uh way of thinking and bringing it to
the table and allowing
the person that is managing the customer
success department or the
relationship uh to see and to understand
the relationships using the data so it's
data-driven
way of
system now understanding that
the key for success in customers in
customer success
area is in the data and you can do
something with that
using ai to leverage it to
to our
you know daily manner this is the key
for success now
i'm not sure they knew how to do that
exactly but
it was the idea and this is what i love
here and and this is how to do and we
are building together ways of how to to
use the right technologies for the right
purposes
uh with all
other aspects of course but
this is the
if you go back now to your childhood a
little bit you know middle school
elementary school who's your why no what
what really guides you
what fascinates you what what sparks
your curiosity
well if you go along back well i think
all the time i was uh
i was kind of a
technological physical geek
first time i had my keyboard was uh
at the age of
ten something like that i remember the
first course i took in
in programming programming i didn't know
english wow so i didn't know the
difference between capital letters and
the
short letters so so you know the the
teacher was writing uh i think uh
i'm not sure what language what it was
i don't really really really know it we
used commodore 64 something like that i
don't know and i just copied from the
board and i did myself you know c
you can write like a capital letter then
you could write it a small letter and i
didn't understand the difference so
using the keyword i made so many
mistakes
i didn't know english
and it took me some times and then so i
knew
i wrote programs before i knew english
so it's kind of helpful
so i uh yeah i love it so it's amazing
and uh
so
it was fascinating it's not that i'm uh
you know a natural programmer
i like to do many other things i think
that uh
i like
physics a lot i was i was interested in
airplanes you know i did like flying
models and
nice models and all kinds of that
i i was
sure that i will be a pilot but gave it
up as soon as i found myself in the
engineering and electronics
i found out that i'm strong with that
and it's amazing
if you look today you know where do you
draw your your daily inspiration we
touched on it a little bit it's about
you know you mentioned working with the
teams and the technology itself but you
know if you look at the day to day when
you wake up in the morning what what
what inspires you
you know and in what you do
so it's like not only in what i do as as
uh
as an investor or as a
as
work but also in all other manners i
think what inspires me the most is that
it's the thing that we are in a global
area era uh
you can go i mean you can
send a beat from here to any place in
the world you can uh create a network
from here
to
every place in the world yeah and this
is this is amazing you know we lost the
amazement with that right it's amazing
i'm going up into it right you grew up
into it but it was never like this
before and only when the cyber started
uh the web and everything will start to
be connected
and
to know in everything that you do that
you can do it globally
makes you think of everything you do
in a globally
in in a global way
and i think this is amazing you know
when the abraham accords
took place and there was like peace
thoughts so
i somehow connected with
muhammad
muhammad madhani from
the uee he has a meetup group of big
data uaes and like that with 2 000
followers
no non-virtual like a physical meetup
group and we decided to
to build something together
you know what are the
chances that i will meet someone that we
never met just with you know virtual and
online and we created something we call
ai square it's arab israeli artificial
intelligence so it's a iai ai square and
ai square like a place uh you know in
the street that you that you talk and
share thoughts and we created this uh
series of uh you know webinars and
meetups all virtual
and what other and then suddenly i got a
phone call from this group from turkey
that they want to cooperate with us
because they want to engage their ai
community with our ai community
what are the chances that i you know
what i told them the first time
well we were in peace 10 years ago and
suddenly something happened between
israel and turkey and they told me uh
well it never happened you know we are
in the high tech we don't mind of uh
politics and uh yeah let's we
we are very open to to do things
together and suddenly i say hey why not
people are people so we went with that
and start collaborating and do
some relationships we have tried to
build a bridge uh
for people to to engage
and it
well i never expected it it just
happened
you know with the computer nothing else
so that's entrepreneurship so this is
this is amazing so uh
i think that's what inspires me the most
and what are a few words that you would
use to describe yourself
a few words so i think uh we didn't
discuss it much but uh there's a part of
me that i'm kind of a hacker and not a
hacker in a way of you know to
penetrate uh
did it you know like a strategically way
but not only that but hacking uh the way
of thinking
like strategic hacking hacking uh not
accepting uh the basic uh
formats and rules trying to
to find the holes on the or the
shortcuts
i think it's part of the israeli you
know spirit and culture but i found out
that i'm doing it uh
pretty well so
i moved on with that
so this is one kind another another
description is my friend
i used to call me mr line you remember
that character yeah he walks on the line
yeah and i always want everything to be
straight and fixed so on i love things
it's not allow things to to be done
right
uh if you're doing something do it right
don't don't don't uh
skip up uh stages and so forth and uh we
called it in in in the army we called it
the ferrari standard
because you know in ferrari when when
well if i'll give you my ferrari keys i
don't have a ferrari done
don't worry but if i'll give you my fair
case you will drive it anyway even if
you don't know where to go you will just
enjoy the driving yeah and
my office in the army was
in front of the ferrari
agency in tel aviv so i got to see all
the all the ferraris there so it became
like a
phrase for the unit like we have to do
our
softwares as a ferrari standard and ui
is the first one to drive it and to see
if it's in the right standard so it's
like
paying attention to the little details
and make sure the all uh complete
solution is is the right way and fits
what it needs
so that makes a lot of sense
so this is me
this was amazing thank you thank you
very much
and i can't wait to see what you're
doing with the disruptive ai and and the
companies that you're working with and i
just love
you know the personal conviction that
you've had throughout your career you've
gotten to to deal with some of the most
incredible things in the cyberspace
transition to the ai space being there
this inflection point where you're
seeing the dissonance between what the
old world and the new world with the new
innovation it you know with the
statistical questions and but then
taking it into the private sector and
understanding the grand scheme of things
in the globalization i just love the
journey and i learned a lot so thank you
very very much and stay safe and
stealthy thank you thank you very much
it was
great fun
you